South Korea's president will visit
president Trump next week to report on
his latest summit with Kim jong-un moon
jaein wrapped up a second day of talks
with the North Korean leader in
Pyongyang this morning their third
meeting of the year produced a series of
pledges on issues from reducing military
tensions to the Olympics South Korea
says Kim is willing to take more steps
towards denuclearization Ben Tracy
returned from North Korea last week and
is tracking this summit from Beijing
been good morning good morning so these
two leaders agreed to quite a bit the
big question now is how much of it will
actually happen and will the u.s. go
along with it now in this latest
declaration North Korea agrees to
permanently shutter its main missile
engine testing site and its launch pad
now this is where the North has tested
several of its intercontinental
ballistic missiles what's significant
here is that Kim Jong moon says he will
allow outside experts to come in and
verify that North Korea has actually
dismantled it the North also says it's
willing to shudder its main nuclear
facilities in Jung Byung but only if the
United States makes some unspecified
reciprocal action North Korea has made
it clear it will not unilaterally
denuclearize now we were in North Korea
last week as the regime marked the
anniversary of North Korea's founding
they did not parade their
intercontinental ballistic missiles or
even mention nuclear weapons at any of
their events but despite what North
Korea is doing and saying publicly
satellite imagery and reports from the
UN show that they are still moving
forward with their nuclear weapons
program they're just doing it much more
quietly Gayle all right Ben Tracy
reporting from Beijing